let's go next to tyler and vancouver our
friendly neighbors to the north
okay hear me yes i can tyler can you
hear me
yes i can tyler i'm doing well excellent
i have a question
i'm sure if you've covered this before
but it seems from afar that the
republican party and its supporters have
laid
claim to this idea of american
patriotism in the name of their cause
and
no one else's um i don't know if it's
become a big
recruiting tool for american right but
it feels like it's everyone who's not
with them is
an anti-american fascist right yeah no
this is this is not new i mean
in i it probably goes back many decades
but
as far as i've been covering politics
during the george w bush era
if you didn't support the war in iraq
you weren't really a patriot that became
a big
a big um talking point then
yeah and so my question is how how has
it become that
the right has laid claim to patriotism
and how can what can the left do
to you know reclaim that from them uh
yet george lakoff has has written about
this quite a bit
the the right has not only succeeded on
taking
patriotism they've succeeded on on
framing and branding on a bunch of
different issues
you know pro-life sounds great
and they succeeded on that tax relief
is another one that george lake wow
that's a relief you're removing the
burden of taxation
this is not unique to patriotism and i i
don't have any
um uh unique ideas on it other than to
say
i would look at lake off on this and
some of his suggestions and
democrats just aren't very good at this
i mean listen if it were me i would say
patriotism should be about look at how
well we take care of everybody from the
standpoint of health care
look at how well designed our cities are
to have great public transit
and green spaces and connection between
richer and poorer
you know none of these things are true
now but like those would be the types of
things for me
that seem like the ones i would want to
be patriotic about
rather than like we have the most
weapons or we
you know have the most guns or or
whatever i think it needs to be a
complete paradigm shift on framing
absolutely agree and just on one more
note on that
is that how how i should
try to figure out the best way to to
kind of ask this is
if if the left's ideas are somehow seen
as anti-american you know like repealing
or
not replaying the second amendment but
you know having stronger gun
uh security kind of stuff how can we
fight against
that being an anti-american value when
it's just not you know it's a
better for the entire country it's
really just a pr it's unfortunately
merely a propaganda and rhetorical war
at this point so you just have to be
better at rhetoric
that that's that simple yeah this is
kind of a shame that's what paul says
come to this day
i know there you go i agree with you i
agree with you i appreciate the call
thanks so much
tyler from vancouver thank you so much
for the call
very much appreciate it